it's officially fall so fire up your TVs
laptops whatever and find a comfy groove
on the couch because the TV show is
worth tweeting about our premiering now
and what should you look out for this
season some new series some old ones and
one refreshing feature racial diversity
take ABC scandal probably America's most
obsessed about show because who doesn't
love a weekly dose of sex politics and
an inside glimpse into Washington's
corrupt ways the show is entering its
fourth season and in case you haven't
seen it it follows the lead character of
Olivia Pope a fiery political fixer in
DC based off an actual woman who
literally fixes important people's
messes she's powerful I do not give up
attractive oh and has also had an
on-and-off illicit love affair with the
President of the United States what do
you want you but a big factor that put
scandal on the map is the fact that its
main actress Kerry Washington is the
first African American female lead to
star in a network drama this popular
since 1974 and as the et comm editor
clay Kane says the way that's resonated
with black audiences is a huge reason
the shows a hit it really is the
audience for this come in and made the
show a big success
Black's quitter for example they have
shown that a show with a
african-american following can be a huge
success on network television
still you better believe that a show
where a black woman fixes DC is gonna
get some race conversations going
especially when she keeps the coming to
a powerful white man I'm feeling a
little I don't know Sally Hemings how
much ten percent about all this but
that's not the point so it is gamble
kinda tore the door down network
television is finally getting at that
that that white people white audiences
can watch a show about the lives of
African Americans and not be afraid
you'll see the mythical and majestic
black family and this season two
additional show starring black leads and
revolving around black lives are
debuting on primetime
first is how to get away with murder
from the same executive producer who
brought you scandal Shonda Rimes the
show stars Viola Davis as a brilliant
law professor who becomes entangled in a
murder plot with her students are you
coming one and then there's blackish a
comedy about a successful black man
struggling to retain his family's
cultural identity in white suburbia I'm
going to need my family to be black not
black-ish now of course racial diversity
isn't just black and white
and while these shows may be better
representing America let's be honest we
can do better
so who do you want to see in primetime
and how else can TV improve its image
let us know lot more download the AJ
plus mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your App Store now